qui gagne à être connu et sauf bonsoir
alors tu sors un double album 23 titre
s'appelle succès fou avec l'éthique du
début c'est-à-dire aline les
marionnettes avec l'époque des albums
les mots bleus señorita tout est bien ce
dans le disque à part la pochette
fichiers de ces risques et ouais mais
bon on est bon de prendre un risque ou
picasso s'appliquer c'est aussi un peu
trop vite fais pas c'est parce
qu'annulant le disque 1 enfin tant que
c'est que ça tu t'en fous toi et un nom
je vous comprends je ne suis pas
d'accord mais bon c'est fait ouais
antennes et à juvisy-sur-orge ton père
était installateur de chauffage central
et elle est étalée sur la côte on se
tâte
la grande époque de la côte d'azur en 9
64 ouais c'est avec une chanson des
demandes et ça plaît à washington ouais
tu le faisais ça que je faisais et
c'était pas connu jetait dans les boîtes
de nuit le voir après jetée dans l'est
dans les pizzas ouais c'était pas connu
j'ai écouté ces gens là où est un
traditionnel ces gens là sur fun radio
carolin un essai sortie en france à un
an après et voit quand je chante et ça
je disais que c'était moi qui la
composent et plus frais mais bon c'est
super
machaie lepage avait 40 alors en 1964 tu
vas gens les peintures rencontre une
fille qui s'appelle aline natta nowitzki
était assistante damas tomato et qui
fait toujours tu écoutais justement
chanté the rising sun il est d'après
pour elle tu as composé ali 65 tube
énorme
il ya eu un procès qu'en amérique jacky
muller parce que ça ressemble à une
chanson qui régit sortie en 62 et l
armement que c'était la romance mais ça
ressemblait vraiment ça ressemblait pas
mal s'il n'y a effectivement bon et un
procès je les perds du blocage du caroux
et 5 kg car ses idées recettes et tout
ça pour rigoler du tout la vraie ouais
mais si j'avais 20 ans je dis rien je
suis fait partie des hommes quittent pas
leur roulotte 1 est en moi ça quand même
mais rangé ma vie alors en 66 staff et
les marionnettes 65 monsieur le
professeur en fait avait la haine des
tubes en fait c'est pas du tout ce que
tu voulais faire toi tu voulais faire du
rock
si vous l'êtes dernier baby à l'ailé au
vigan ouais mais c'est moi j'en ai plus
fière du blues parce que tu vois ce qui
m'a bercé dans les années 60 c'est quand
même au coeur l'acting kings climat au
séjour n'apparaisse que c'est pas le
fait d'être venu
un tube heures français par rapport au
bout ce que tu voulais chanter qu'il a
donné une espèce de n2 toi et qui t'a
amené à faire toutes ces conneries parce
qu'on a fait après des conneries là
partir de 67 non projet mullinder moi
non c'est l'image que j'ai donné c'est
pas de ma faute c'est la faute des gens
ont compris qu'en fait on fait une
tresse de presse un garde est nul c'est
vrai que pour un gala par jour le pognon
qui arrivait comme il pas possible tu
t'achètes un flat avec terrasse dans le
xvième les bolides enfin tu es parti
dans un drôle de trip un peu un peu pop
star serbe l'a plus la dépense et
l'alcool quand même bien les connaît
comment la défense s'attache sarajevo a
donc effectivement je connais pas
beaucoup
ouais ce qui est un peu par la suite
nous empêcher de commandos de vous
écrire et quand au bout d'un an et demi
deux ans je suis là c'est grave la junte
moi j'ai pas trouvé une idée j'ai vallée
oui parce qu'on 69 tu t'es retrouvé
ruiné disparu quoi un moment tel trou
noir oui 68 60 60 points 4
j'étais bien j'étais loin de tous âges
quant à elle j'étais en fait néanmoins
elle est intervenue en 73 c'était
gymnastique je me faire pardonner je
fais de la peinture je suis sage et là
ça fait tous ses albums et jean michel
jarre est sympa mais bon c'est une
époque formidable sens soit voulait
depuis longtemps donc ce trou noir c'est
avait servi finalement faire c'est avait
servi à que ouais mais tous les trois
ans à venir que j'étais voilà fisc
aujourd'hui tous les tournois de et si
les trous noirs comme ans que je suis
que je crois qu aller vite parce que
j'ai besoin de ça moi je peux pas
toujours pas toujours
j'ai commencé à être aimé par la
critique à ce moment là et c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui des gens comme comme
bâillon par exemple 10 ya un côté yéyé
pourri chez christophe un peu mencé
bonne image quand même un peu gérard
manset ils trouvent ça aller à bayonne
il est du gouvernement ce que mon nom
mais je pense qu'il est quand même dans
un à l'écart de tout ça je pense que mes
côtés y est pourri c'est vrai un peu
comme maintenant ses albums ouais peu
sournois un peu bizarre oui bon c'est le
problème de ces albums analyse
aujourd'hui par rapport à l'album est en
train de faire tu vois c'est un peu le
texte quoi est ce que tu en entends
monge fait un truc comme merci de jeunes
venus au mariage et là j'en suis fier
parce que c'est toi tu l'as mis dans la
vieille ville ben ouais bien sûr parce
que c'est tout ce que j'aime j'ai écrit
un truc je me surprends moi même analyse
señorita les monges loïc comment moi je
suis un excellent homme s'appelait pas
être construit le dire on va peut-être
me prendre pour un marc joly même si l
un de vos cunego ouah je peux écrire des
trucs méfiance